hey subs & welcome to the series where
we explore all the hidden things in Dark
Souls 2 as usual let's not use the like
in the dislike system as a measure of
appreciation instead let's use it as a
point system if you know everything in
this video then leave a dislike if you
learn something new though feel free to
leave a like decide now whether you want
to play this game and let's get into it
number one as displayed on screen by my
brilliant accuracy with the moonlight
greatsword if you damage one of these
Cobalts then they'll all come and attack
you I don't know if you've ever tried to
hit one of them with your fists when you
first start the game but it's really
damn hard
it's possible though see your reward for
this amazing feat is getting ripped to
shreds you owned it if you found the
last boss too easy on your first
playthrough don't worry number two is
here for you because I almost feel like
from decided to make the start of new
game+ in the tutorial harder than the
end of your first playthrough in new
game as soon as you start you're
surrounded by hollow falconers who are
exclusive to new game+ as far as I know
these falconers are a hundred percent
true to their name they throw Falcons at
you which will try to peck your eyes out
which really is just that first
experience that every masochistic Souls
player wants number three after a
welcoming start in new game+ you go into
this Shack where old women make fun of
you for being destined to die over and
over again it's great
ever wonder though what happens if you
give them the sword to the face that
they so truly deserve the one named
strollin gives six human effigies and
her sisters give none so it's not
entirely worth it but sometimes you
can't put a price on satisfaction
speaking of which you'll notice that the
old women have names that's number four
it's never mentioned in-game so I don't
really expect you to leave a like for
not knowing this one but in the official
guide it tells you their names based on
when each of them talks in the cutscene
the outspoken one in the middle is
called straw in and the other two are
called grant and Morel number five
relates to their house made Milla Beth
Milla Beth the housemaid handles the
chores for the fire keepers and as such
she's holding a ladle and yes I know
what you're thinking we want that ladle
we need it it's all we ever wanted in a
so right now she's not that happy with
us because we killed the fire keepers
her family has been watching over for
generations and if we kill her she won't
even give us her ladle so here's how to
get it if you kill the ogres on the
beach near the stone coffin then she'll
give it to you just so it can help you
on your journey you have proven yourself
to the forest we have little to offer
except perhaps these may they bring
fortune to your journey how a ladle will
help you on your journey is beyond me
it breaks in like 10 hits and call me
crazy guys but I think this might be a
joke weapon
goodbye ladle oh I mentioned the stone
coffin just before and this is number
six so if you're like me you got into
the coffin and you couldn't quite
realize what changed and it's quite
ingenious really something about your
character does change when you get in
but you're instantly attacked by enemies
when you get out so it's unlikely that
you'll notice the coffin swaps your
things betwixt changing you from a man
into a woman or vice versa 7 there's a
hidden path off to the left here with an
ogre further along if you manage to kill
him this early in the game then you'll
get a stone ring which increases the
amount of poise damage you do to enemies
it's a great early game ring number
eight have you ever wondered what you'd
get if you managed to light all the
torches and things betwixt us feels like
you should get something but maybe I've
been playing too much Legend of Zelda
because nothing happens if you do now 9
is a door and a pathway that's fairly
hidden if you made this jump within the
first tree on the right then you might
have noticed this ladder on your way
back
climate jump down to a slightly higher
platform and there's a door with a
cracked red eye orb inside off to the
right and number 10 like in every Souls
game there's this nest where you can
drop items and receive other items in
return in Dark Souls 2 there are four
different items you can put in the nest
four different tiers of rewards prism
stones give crappy rewards like homeward
bones or burrs small smooth and silky
stones give titanite souls effigies and
cracked orbs smooth and silky stones
give different types of upgrade stones
and
sure find something give slabs a great
ring or a range of weapons one of the
rarest weapons you can get is the
channelers trident and you look I got a
trident awesome yeah if you drop smooth
and silky stones here you have a chance
of getting the Trident which is
technically only a reward for trading
and petrified something but sometimes
you can trade as smooth as they dropped
another Trident oh my god
you
you
you
on a journey without rest